they say it's better for wisdom to come
late than never at all and for the
giants the wisdom came about two weeks
late because they've decided after only
two games to make daniel jones the
starting quarterback why week three well
they realize that eli manning shouldn't
have been the starter from week one and
really this is the closest thing you're
ever gonna get to an admission from the
giants they should have just made the
sixth overall pick the starting
quarterback from the beginning of the
regular season they made him that sixth
overall pick for a reason eli manning
has been the guy who's fallen out of
favor in new york for a reason and i
know that there's a sentimentality
that's attached to this even though
giants governor john merrill would
violently disagree with that that's the
reason why they've gotten off to the
start with eli manning and i'm not
saying they would have won either of
those games with daniel jones but why
not let the future begin now and as in
now as of two weeks ago not now as of
right now moving forward but again it's
better that they made that decision now
instead of doubling down and continuing
to play eli manning the fans are ready
for it the media is ready for it jones
seems to be ready for it and the giants
finally ready to make the move that
maybe needed to be made a couple of
years ago because eli manning has not
been the same guy that he was when they
won the super bowl back in the 2011
season and they have been out of the
playoffs far more often than in the
playoffs since then now they begin the
road back with a new quarterback
and a guy who may still end up in the
hall of fame standing on the sidelines
and watching
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports